Nos dicen que: "Los administradores de
la escuela están considerando cambiar el
reglamento. Realizaron una encuesta a un grupo
de estudiantes, miembros del personal y padres
de familia, sobre si estaban de acuerdo con
el nuevo reglamento. La siguiente gráfica de
mosaicos resume sus resultados", y nos preguntan
"¿Cuáles de estos enunciados se ven reflejados
en la gráfica de mosaicos?" Pausa este video y
trata de resolverlo por tu cuenta. Escoge cuáles
de estas opciones se pueden inferir a partir
de la gráfica, pueden ser más de una las que
tienes que escoger. Bueno, pues trabajemos
juntos en esto. Antes de ver las opciones,
veamos qué podemos interpretar de la gráfica.
Lo que hace esta gráfica, a diferencia de las
gráficas de barras segmentadas, es que usa
el ancho para mostrarnos cuántos estudiantes,
cuántos miembros del personal y cuántos padres
de familia se muestrearon, ¿ok?, cuántos se
encuestaron. Podemos ver que más de la mitad
de las personas encuestadas fueron estudiantes,
y que la cantidad de padres y de personal se ve
similar. En términos de ¿quiénes están de acuerdo
con el nuevo reglamento?, esos están dibujados
de azul claro, ¿ok? Pero parece que es poco
probable que los estudiantes estén de acuerdo;
se ve que es bastante probable que los miembros
del personal estén de acuerdo, ¿ok?, porque la
mayoría del personal está de acuerdo, aquí vemos
que la mayoría del personal está de acuerdo, y
los padres están de los dos lados. Y ahora sí,
veamos cuáles de estos enunciados son consistentes
con lo que acabamos de observar. "Los padres de
familia apoyan el nuevo reglamento con menor
probabilidad que los demás". No, esto no es
cierto; los que aprueban el nuevo reglamento con
menor probabilidad son los estudiantes -por aquí-,
ellos definitivamente son los que tienen
la menor probabilidad: el porcentaje de los
estudiantes que aprueban el nuevo reglamento es
el menor, así es que esta opción no es correcta.
"Más de la mitad de los encuestados son
estudiantes". Esto sí parece ser el caso,
porque si nos fijamos en todo este ancho, que es
el total de los encuestados, y lo comparamos con
este ancho, el de los estudiantes, podemos ver
que abarca más de la mitad, ¿ok?, parece que es
el cincuenta y tantos por ciento o incluso el 60
por ciento; así es que me gusta esta opción. Y,
finalmente: "Hubo más alumnos que contestaron que
'No', que miembros del personal y padres de familia
combinados". Pues observemos cuántos estudiantes
contestaron que no, los que contestaron que no
están de color azul oscuro, son esta área
por acá. Podemos colorear toda esta área,
y los miembros del personal y padres de
familia que contestaron que no combinados
es esta otra área por acá, y se ve que el total
de los estudiantes que contestaron que no, toda
esta área por acá, es mucho más grande que el área
de acá, por lo que también me gusta esta opción.